hambre en América Latina y el Caribe
entre 2015 y 2021 la inseguridad
alimentaria aumentó en casi 100 millones
de personas mientras que de 2019 a 2021
el hambre se incrementó en 13,2 millones
de personas alcanzando un total de 56,5
millones son datos regionales del último
informe de la FAO el documento evidencia
básicamente tres grandes desafíos El
primero un salto en las cifras del
hambre e inseguridad alimentaria en los
últimos años el segundo el costo más
alto de una dieta saludable en
comparación a otras regiones del mundo
en el contexto inflacionario global y el
tercero el incremento sostenido de la
obesidad y el sobrepeso con impactos en
la salud y en la economía pero más allá
del hambre destaca otro dato 131
millones de personas en el Continente no
tienen acceso a una dieta saludable esto
en una región donde hay un potencial de
producción alimentaria que podría
sostener a 1.300 millones de personas el
doble de la población de América Latina
no debemos olvidar que esta situación
afecta particularmente a las poblaciones
más vulnerables pequeños agricultores
mujeres Rurales y poblaciones indígenas
y afrodescendientes las cuales destinan
un mayor porcentaje de sus ingresos a la
compra de alimentos revertir esta
situación precisa de una profunda
transformación de nuestros sistemas
alimentarios para que sean sostenibles e
inclusivos y permitan a todas las
personas tener una alimentación de
calidad la pandemia la guerra y la
crisis climática tienen como efectos el
alza de precios de fertilizantes y
alimentos por lo que la región vive un
alarmante panorama en seguridad
alimentaria nutricional